- Bonsoir.
- Comment voyez-vous
cision?
- En fait, pour vous dire la
vérité quand j'ai entendu les
extraits de jugement ce matin
j'ai constaté les réactions, ma
première opinion, etc. me dire
que l'on va encore dire que le
système de justice ne fonctionne
pas. Ce qui n'est pas exact à
mon sens. C'est sûr que l'onpari
sont troublantes pour l'opinion,
qui le sont moins. Les décisions
sont favorables à cuisante
matière cela fasse
l'appellation. Avec le courant,
moi aussi, c'est peut-être plus
marquant avec l'agression
sexuelle mais je veux pas me
prononcer sur la justesse de la
peine mais reste questionné
décision qui bien sûr est
étonnante. Il y a eu des
réactions comme ce
- Est-ce que c'est un cas isolé
ou que finalement
représenter des cas qui existent
mais qui ne font pas parler?
- C'est ça. L'absolution,
qu'elle soit conditionnelle ou
inconditionnelle, ce n'est pas
une mesure exceptionnelle.
- Qu'estest justement
l'absolution conditionnelle?
- C'est l'absence de casierre la
personne coupable et condamnée,
mais pas de casier judiciaire
avec ou sans condition. Dans ce
cas il y a des conditions parce
que l'approbation de trois
imposait. C'est sur que j'ai dit
que c'est une peine qui n'est
pas exceptionnelle. C'est sûr
que les gestes qui ont été posés
sont très graves. Souvent en
matière d'agression sexuelle
qu'on a des absolutions, c'est
dans le cas avec le toucher par-
dessus les vêtements, très,
très... une tape sur les fesses
par exemple. Cinq dossiers pour
lesquels on pourrait avoir une
peine d'absolution qui sont
imposées. Dans ce cas, ce sont
des gestes très graves et le
juge a insisté sur les facteurs
atténuantes. Pas beaucoup des
facteurs aggravants qu'il a
trouvés. Les critères pour
l'absolution, c'est important de
le comprendre. Il faut que ce
soit dans l'intérêt de la
victime. C'est pou a
parlé de voyage. Et il faut que
ce ne soit pas contraire à
l'intérêt public. Ça n'a pas à
être dans l'intérêt public mais
cela doit pas être contraire.
- J'aimerais revenir aux
critères d'intérêt public dans
un instant mais vous avez parlé
de voyage. Ce que le juge a dit
que pour permettre à cet
ingénieur de pouvoir voyager, ir
judiciaire parce que ça pourrait
empêcher. Est-ce que ça crée un
système finalement de deux poids
deux mesures face à nue aut
personne avec un emploi moins
prestigieux.
- La personne en question
n'avait pas à voyager. On peut
se dire que c'est approprié pour
un jeune qui ne vient pas
d'améliorer chez, qui n'a pas
une profession libérale parce
que par exemple pour faire son
métier de la const
doit aller dans un pénitencier.
On peut penser l'absolution pour
un artiste qui doipourpourpourpr
des expositions. Alors, dans ce
cas, ce ue
l'accusé n'avait pas à voyager
pour son travail. Ce n'est pas
une preuve que les faits avaient
voyagée., si
la personne à voyager, ça peut
être important de ne pas avoir
de casier judiciaire.
- Maintenant l'intérêt public.
Est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que dans ce cas,
cette peine sert l'intérêt
public ou ça vient ébranler la
confiance dans le système de
justice dans le cas d'agression
sexuelle?
- La confiance du système par le
public fait partie des
considérations lorsque le corps
doit déterminer si c'est
contraire à l'intérêt public.
Alors ici, pas le
constater que le public par
confiancn den den den den den de
la justice devant décision comme
celle-là. C'est ce que l'on voit
depuis ce matin. On sait que
c'est déjà en appel. Une plainte
est aussi le poids des gens sont
Hakola. Alors, c'est un critère
qui a coous
les facteurs de détermination de
la peine, tous les principes de
détermination doivent être
considérés au compris
l'importance de la dissuasion
générale. Il s'agit d'agression
sexuelle, les mouvements sociaux
font évoluer le droit. C'est sûr
que le droit risque d'évoluer et
de changer avec un mouvement
comme celui que l'on vient de
vivre dans le monde avec moi
aussi. Mais sur la question de
la confiance du public, c'est
l'un des critères à considérer
pour décider s'il absolution
serait contraire à l'ordre
public.
- C'est un cas qui va suivre son
cours comme vous l
Robert, merci d'avoir démyst